I'm Val and I'm Max and I'm putting the
brothers in the hot seat for a little
game of sipping spill
Dancing with the Stars is moving back to
ABC what did you guys make of that great
yeah great I feel bad for everybody that
subscribed uh
um going back to network television kind
of feels not nostalgic but it feels
right to be back at our original home
but again Disney plus has done wonders
for us last season okay so what was your
initial reaction when you both found out
that Tyra Banks was leading dancing with
I was very happy for Alfonso that was my
first foremost reaction it wasn't the
negativity towards that Tyra or whether
I think she did a good job or not it was
we can turn that page move on and now
I'm super happy for this dude and just
to speak on Tyra I you know she came in
at a very turbulent time in the show in
entertainment in general we were going
through covid a lot of that uh you know
on stage rules of distance and all that
stuff kind of I think
was a hurdle for her and for all of us
to kind of bond and connect and and I
think she you know she held it down so
so it's three seasons of again hard work
and and she was always very kind to
everybody
suppose uh what did you think about this
choice
we were really happy for Alfonso I mean
no it's uh I think
oh she's familiar there's a lot of ties
and I think because of that
it'll it'll add to the show and she'll
do a great job but can we expect you Val
to come back
yes I would love to be back on Dancing
With the Stars hey Jenna Jenna would
love to be back
and Peter would love to be back
well Val you just welcomed your first
child right yes four months today what's
been like to see your brother kind of
step into this role as a dad
I mean it's been great yeah you know
I've been father bigger for this week
fatherhood is incredible uh the greatest
responsibility I've ever experienced now
What's it gonna be like for you going
from one to two are you ready for that I
think as long as we're man on man is
good then after that zone defense is
where it gets complicated you know three
to two is going to be tough but we're
ready for to you know again we we just
have a
little network of like the other dance
Pros who are also pregnant who you know
it's it's just so much fun to see them
all communicate you're gonna be like a
bullpen just for the babies they should
yeah next is going to be what is that
movie with you stop it right now
but before baby number two comes along
Max and Val have a new Venture saber
after hours kicking off June 3rd in Napa
Valley is a dance infused theatrical
wine tasting and only ET was behind the
scenes at their rehearsal
[Applause]
[Music]
Savor after hours uh sir I can tell you
fellas that sounds sexy all right what
are you serving up this audience
some sexy
we're evolving and just like wine you
know you age and you become wiser better
smarter more creative and and this show
is going to be a reflection of that all
right so given the theme of the show I
have to ask have you dance slash
performed drunk before
oh you're not even gonna spill they're
thirsty folks I'm gonna name drop but
Joey fatone's first item into his
dressing room when he moved in was a
margarita machine okay there you go and
say no more so I want to know what is
the last thing you each did to seduce
your significant other I mean I like to
romance and I like to seduce my my
significant other through poetry oh he
just showed up walked in one time on on
set who was a better dancer you is it or
your wife is it a part that's a good one
yeah our wives That's a good one I am
fourth on the
four of us list of like trophy dance
trophies let's just call it what it is
right so that's why I stay out of these
conversations I just show up do my thing
and let the people decide this size
you know what out of the four of them
I'm gonna go back to the big sexy ones
all right so who's the better looking
brother
I don't have to sip on that I mean
that's that's
he definitely has a much better facial
structure yes that's the end of the game
but I did want to raise a toast though
for Len Goodman what was the impact Len
had on your guys's lives and what will
you miss about it Len gave a show that
has changed our lives and and the life
of a lot of dancers a credibility that I
don't think otherwise would have made
that show successful and and live on for
now going into season 32. when he earned
that Authority not just on camera but
behind the scenes for you know 50 years
of being in competitive ballroom dancing
he felt like uh you know a Granddad to
us our our dance Grandad he gave
credibility to that desk and he in his
voice the way he said it
now that we have a little liquid courage
I heard that you guys might teach me a
Dancer too during rehearsal so should we
get to it yeah let's do it saber after
hours is a very passionate show and so
let's just cut straight to the
choreography that is the most passionate
I'm ready
um this is a dip and because you guys
are matching I feel like you guys
already have immediate chemistry I'm
dipping him right the height is
incredible and after a little practice
look at him and
and then surrender oh there you go
so he goes one two
you go three four
you go five six
step in seven eight seven eight
one wow okay cool I'm a pro hey I got
moves you've never seen all right there
you go and The Crowd Goes Wild
[Music]